今天分享的课题内容是何谓原创性
歌迷与歌词文字
首先原创当然很重要
原创对于每个艺术领域来讲都是重中之重
但是歌词有点不太一样
歌词是通俗文化
通俗文化讲究的是流通性跟影响力
只要流通性跟影响力够
不见得说每一个歌词都一定要原创
但是歌名的排列结构最好有几句
是很特别的原创新
我在前面的几堂课有分享过一个概念
就是音乐是情感的催化剂
所有的音乐就是旋律
音乐旋律是听觉的
歌词可以说是音乐的剧情
它包含了故事线跟情节
还有男女主角的个性都在里面
所以歌词可以理解成帮一个model穿上衣服
那旋律是这个model的骨架
所以基本上一首好的音乐呢
这个model基本上骨架要漂亮
如果男生可要180
那180的前提下穿上任何衣服
只要裁剪得宜
只要是设计过的
适合那个场所的
然后走出来就是加分
所以呢就是这样子的结合
去想象词跟曲的搭配是很微妙的
所以
一切记对歌词创作有兴趣的朋友
最好是身边有一个partner
他也从事着作曲
可能是文笔稍微欠佳
不太能用文字去表达故事
或是用文字没办法把故事讲的完整
或副歌有记忆点
他可能韵脚上啊
歌词结构的经营上啊
画面感比较弱
那跟这样一个PANNER结合
那是最好的一个组合
会帮助你的歌词比较快的让人家注意
或是有能见度或者是曝光
接下来我们就先介绍歌词的一个原创性好
我先挑十个是我自己创作的一个歌词的名字
来做一个介绍
那首先千里之外
千里之外它就不具备原创性
它就是一个常见的词汇
但是用在那个时空点
用在歌的整个主轴是刚刚好
然后再来
我是如此相信
因为他句子拖得长
它反而具备原创性
因为他虽然很口语哦
但是这么口语完整的把它罗列出来
当歌的名字哦
它反而是不会有重复
你说牵引之后还有可能重复到
我是如此
相信是基本上不会有人跟你重复的
所以他那个原创性是很微妙的一种呃定义
但是今天大致上跟各位沟通
你就更清楚所谓的原创性哦
原来不是一定要完全的句子
不是的是他很口语没有关系
但是拿来当歌的名字使用是首次很少见
那它就具备了原创性
再来不该不该的话也是算原创性
因为一般人讲话是不应该或应该
他不会用
不该很短
这得具备原创性
但接下来还有首歌
我写给林俊杰的
就是将故事写成我们
它实在是有点长
但是他基本的故事的精神
歌名就已经传达了歌名
最有力量的是一看歌名
就是他故事的结构就是最精准
最漂亮的歌名
发如雪也是具备原创性
然后再来是东风破
东风没有原创性了
但是加个破字有点像仿宋的词牌名
它就具备了原创性
那青花瓷是一个瓷器器皿的名词
它完全不具备原创性
青花瓷它虽然不具备原创性
但是第一次把瓷器的器皿拿来当歌的名字
我想他就是第一次用了瓷器的分类里面
它是很常见的
但是在歌词的领域里面
他确实很罕见的
那这样子的运作也是可以的
在爷爷泡的茶
爷爷是常见的词汇
茶也是
但是爷爷泡的茶有个动作
有个动词的感觉
所以它也具备原创性
红尘客栈
红尘是常见的词汇
客栈也是
但是红尘歌在一旦结合之后
它就具备了原创性
它就是字句的排列组合
让人家去熟记是第一要务
但是如果你排列组合是比较少人用过的
那个是最好的一个选项
缘分一道桥也是缘分
你们缘分啊
谁跟谁有缘分啊
那个基本上就是常见的词汇了
桥也是
但是缘分一道桥它就变成非常有创意
而且根本不可能有人用过
因为谁会去把缘分变成桥变成一个形容呢
所以缘分一道桥它的原创性就很够很浓
记住了歌名的原创性
不是这个词汇没有人看过
不是的
是它的排列组合要灵活
要生动
两个常见的字可能红尘跟客栈
可是你一旦把它并成哥的名字
那他就具备了原创性
像我之前有一首歌叫兰亭序
我写那首歌是为了
向王羲之的那个兰亭集序致敬
歌迷写完之后发表后
我有点后悔
你知道为什么吗
因为他的副歌是无关风月
其实无关风月
当歌迷会更有力量
而且原创性会更足更好
但是已经用了嘛
他那那就用了
所以各位同学取歌名的时候注意
就是说
如果你的歌词的讯息量可以支撑这个常用字
那你就大胆的用
没有关系
像青花瓷一样
就大胆的用
那如果说你的歌词的词汇
好像有点小小的弱了一点
那就在歌名上取创意
让人家先记住你的歌名
起码有印象分数
哎呦这个歌名取得很好哦
起码增加了人家对你这首歌的牢记
因为讯息量太多了
流行音乐太多了
当谁也记不住谁的时候
有时候歌名的创意
这个时候就会发挥关键性的力量
接下来我介绍一些呃
其他的词作者所写的一些歌的名字
其实歌名我是随机的挑选
那基本上以能见度为主要的考量
就是说他不管他的年代放在哪里
它有一定的能见度
香水有毒
就是胡杨林的歌香水一样嘛
就是常见常见的一个一个词汇嘛
那有毒有毒是很口语那一个名词加一个口语
那它其实就成立了
香水有毒
如果你叫香水其实就没有
所以它叫香水有毒
基本上大家知道这个一定是悲伤的情歌
因为它有毒嘛
然后女人香有毒那种感觉
然后再是郭源潮
是宋冬野的这个歌词
也得到金曲奖的最佳作词人奖
这个名字就很特别
特别到你还搞不清楚什么意思
就很符合宋冬野的一个创作的个性
再来就是呃情敌贝多芬
贝多芬是一个音乐家嘛
他是个专有人名
那情敌是常用
但是你把情敌放在贝多芬前面了
他就具备了创意
是这样子去理解这个问题的
就是说这堂课希望大家好好的去听
你就完全知道是哦
歌名的创意
有些是排列组合的创意
有些是两个常用字并排的创意
然后这个创意的发挥的空间很大
而不是一定要很罕见的字眼
大壮的我们不一样
这首歌曾经也是有一阵子很流行
那我们不一样
其实哎你跟我不一样
诶
我们都一样
还是很口语的
但是只要是口语的字数够长
基本上不会有重复的疑虑
是可以拿来当歌的名字的
没有问题
而且他是歌词里面的记忆点好
再来是牧马城市
毛不易的木马城市一样的问题嘛
就是说城市是很很常见的
但木马城市就有想象空间了
诶木马不是应该草原吗
不是应该乡村吗
木马居然跟都会感的城市结合在一起哦
大家可能对这个歌有点好奇
他是民谣风吗
是乡愁吗
是讲乡愁的吗
最起码对这个歌的名字有了一个印象
接下来是陈雪凝的这一首
你的酒馆对我打了烊
这首歌的歌的名字让人家就是印象很深刻
当初听到这首歌的时候
歌的名字基本上就记住了
你的酒馆对我打了烊
凡是歌手的名字记不太住人
还是新人嘛
所以证明说这个歌的名字取得很好
他有点像拟人化酒馆
怎么会对人打了烊呢
所以这样子取名的方法
有点像新思的语法跟结构
我觉得是还蛮好的
一个创意
接着成名在望
成名在望
他歌的名字上就没有直截了当的创意
但是它符合它的旋律
它符合他旋律的那种热情
或是他的节奏比较偏摇滚的歌迷
不是一定要有新的意思
但是如果你是新人
或者是说你希望从歌名就打下一些基础分
那歌名的一个创意还是要好好的思索
还有一首刚好遇见你
李玉刚的
刚好遇见你
其实这五个字很口语
那他的字数其实没有那么的长
没有像你的酒馆对我打量那么的长
所以呢他基本上还是有记忆点
但他那种记忆点不是马上就记得住的
需要借由歌手的知名度
跟他的旋律的一个记忆点去强化它的歌名
还有墨那英的墨单一个字拿来当歌的名字
这个基本上就有创意了
因为大家会讲沉默吗
会讲寂寞
那他居然只有一个字
默直截了当来当歌名
最后一个是成都
赵雷的成都
成都是四川的一个地名
就像西安台北一样
它基本上是没有任何创意的
但是这首歌却非常非常的红
他的旋律
他的歌手的嗓音
它里面的故事线强化了这首歌的内涵
虽然他的歌的名字是一个城市的地名
完全不具备原创性
但是没有关系
记得取歌名就是这样子
不是说一定要很罕见的字去组合
或是大家意想不到的东西
不是的
一定要恰如其分
要看你的故事
看歌词的通篇的内容
还有旋律
这些都会影响取歌名的一种方向
跟散发出来的影响力
歌名的创意不仅仅只是字意义上的创意哦
他要跟整首歌做连接
做联想跟旋律相符合
跟歌词的故事有贯穿
然后再去找一个关键字拿来当歌的名字
这才是最好的一个选项
而且歌的有趣还会在这里
不同民族
不同的民族气质也会影响一个曲风
可能像重金属
北欧重金属
重金属的土壤一定是很酷寒的地方
很酷寒的地方生存不易
所以那边的人的性格比较直爽
你也可以说喝了酒之后比较暴烈
摇滚基本上以内地来讲的话
偏北方就偏南一点
比较温暖
就云南云南有个很厉害的摇滚乐团
就很奇怪
所以他也可以拥有
这是那个土壤
那个土壤没办法支撑
日本有个音乐形态叫演歌
因为日本对于死亡这种理解很奇妙
他某种程度他觉得死亡是一种美
像樱花一样瞬间凋谢
所以演歌是日本一个很特别的音乐形态
通常都偏曲调
都偏悲伤
南洋地区可能都偏民谣
因为南方多雨
植物生长容易
所以基本上生存比较相对而言
不像北方那么的困难
像雷鬼月
在牙买加
也就是黑人的那个族群
那个土壤才会有雷鬼乐
拍子跟一般流行音乐不一样
气候民族性会影响音乐的曲风的分布
但不是完全因为现在全球化了嘛
各种音乐流通贯通
再上网络世界很发达
但基本上他还是个脉络可循
董阿志老师
他跟我说
你知道什么音乐像草书吗
我回答不出来
我毕竟不是书法底的
我是爱好书法
热爱书法
他跟我讲说是爵士乐
爵士乐的曲式跟拍子和弦是自由的
那我延伸的想象
我觉得灵魂越像狂潮
他的线条更自由
几乎没有规律可循
然后金草今天的金金草像爵士乐
就是有个分页
那我就觉得哇好特别哦
原来音乐跟书法还可以做结合
那种结合是想象力的结合
那种结合是丰富了我们对事物判断的价值哦
原来这个世界上抽象的东西可以是绘画
也可以是书法
也可以是音乐
你可以把灵魂乐当做是抽象的绘画
这样子的对比
你就觉得哇音乐丰富我们的内心世界
原来抽象可以是灵魂乐
然后原来表现主义可能是RMV
他只表现他的节奏
就说这是个比喻
那我觉得说你今天去学习各个领域的知识
有这样子的心态去观察
因为创作来自于观察
你会得到意想不到的收获好
接下来我们介绍一下歌词
第一首是比较算是近期的一个创作
叫我是如此
相信一样是周同学的一个曲
A one
第一行
鸟群离开了森林
整座天空很灰心
请记住哦
鸟群离开了森林
这句话没有创意
就像乌鸦离开了巢穴一样
蚂蚁离开了蚁窝
但是第二句整座天空很灰心
把这个拉回来了
你可以说救回来了
记住歌词的创意
不见得
整篇a one全部有创意
不需要
但是你一定要交错交错好
他的第二行是蝴蝶不再被吸引
玫瑰盛开的很安静哦
玫瑰盛开是没有声音的
还是植物啊
哦很安静
你就觉得诶这个歌词好很特别
远方的风雨不停
城市苍白而孤寂
徘徊无助的人群焦虑着何时放晴
这个放晴是对照之前的
因为之前上面写风雨不停
这整段两句比较有创意
就是整座天空很灰心
玫瑰盛开的很安静
其他基本上是常用语
众人是这两句
就把所有的主歌的文字的精致度给加了分
故事里能毁坏的只有风景哦
这句话就有原创性哦
故事里能毁坏的只有风景
为什么哦
谁也摧毁不了我们的梦境
梦境怎么摧毁
梦境是没办法摧毁的
这两句都有创意
弦月旁的流星划过了天际
这个就是画面感而已
这句话其实没有创意的
我许下的愿望该向谁去说明
陨石在浩瀚的宇宙间旅行
允把陨石比喻成旅行
这句话还可以创意
还有有一点点璀璨的夜空里漫天的水晶哦
这个就是很特别了
因为我把星星比喻成水晶
我的祷告终于有了回音
这句话其实一太普通了
是第二句救了他
璀璨的夜空里漫天的水晶
记得整段里面有一行或两行有创意
整首歌词会被救回来
也不能说救会加分
好再来副歌
我是如此相信在背后支撑的是你
反而副歌的低压是完全口语哦
口语到不行哦
有时候会这样子刻意的营造
因为副歌是记忆点
是听歌者情感煽动的字句排列
有时候刻意用口语也没有关系
因为你在聆听歌曲的时候
你整个被旋律感动了
整个被歌手的vocal吸引了
你有时候会忽略到副歌的第一行是很平淡的
所以呢这样子的字句是偶尔出现是可以的
但你不能通篇都是这样子
一直与我并肩而行
仰望等太阳升起
听见鸟群回来的声音
我跟你讲
这副歌只有第三行是漂亮的
因为我的a one的第一行是鸟群离开了森林
整座天空很灰心
那我副歌的最后一行听见鸟群回来的声音
把他拉回来了
否则副歌的前两行是很无聊的句子
你看咯
我是如此相信
在背后支撑的是你一直与我并肩而行
仰望等太阳升起
这个如果是新人在比稿
如果我是评委
我就把他打掉了
这个歌词谁都写得出来
所以记得精彩
有创意的句子是可以出现在段落里面
有那些段落支撑整首歌
人家会觉得诶这个歌还不错
但是你不能通篇都是这样子
为我守候的是你给我坚定的信心
哈哈这个我是评委的话
一样登就海选都进不了
第二行是关键
双手弹奏出黎明
黎明怎么能被弹奏呢
最后一句更漂亮
原来爱如此的动听
记得漂亮的句子要穿插使用
你不能通篇都飘到那个就很硬了
很紧张了
而且会腻
所以交错的使用是对的
那经过这样子的解释
各位同学可能会更清楚
那接下来我们再分享下一首
这首叫不该不该
是周冬学跟张惠妹合唱的一个男女对唱的歌
通常男女对唱的情歌
一开始的a one a two都会独立的
比如可能这个歌手唱一段
下一段是这个歌手唱
那有时候会进入副歌的时候
第一行可能主要的歌手唱这个专辑是周同学的
所以周同学唱第一行他是合音
合音的
234行就和音一起唱
通常哪里对唱的歌会这种形式
那我大概分享一下
假装我们还在一块
我真的演不出来
还是不习惯
你不在这身份转换太快
其实这这两行都其实都还好
画面里不需要旁白
却谁都看得出来是我情绪涌了上来
想哭却一片空白
这整句话是比上一段好
但是也没有漂亮突出的句子好
再来雪地里相爱
他们说零下已结晶的誓言不会坏哦
又把他救回来了
但爱的状态却不会永远都冰封而透明的存在
这个句子一样是好的哦
就是推翻了你的上一句
自己推翻自己
男女交往的初期
一定会把自己最好的一面给对方看
所以人家说相爱容易相处难
所以初恋时期或热恋时期是没有问题的
你只看到我最好的一面
然后我也让你看到最好的一面
那等到相处的时候
意见上习惯上的冲突才正开始
副歌的第一行
你还是住在我的回忆里不出来
因为有些分手的对象
你可能嘴巴讲说哦
已经忘了
已经已经没有感觉啦
但是他就住在你的脑海里
住在你的心里
他是不出来的
什么时候出来
不知道
除非你又有新的恋爱对象了
或时间真的拖比较长了
你才慢慢的淡忘
周同学唱的是你还是住在我的回忆里不出来
她指的是女方不出来
女方反而比较释怀
让我们微笑离开
让故事留下来
我们曾经相处过的欢乐就让他留下来
因为我已经知道是谁唱哪一段
所以歌词唱出去的意思是代表那个人的想法
那个人的想法
所以他们的角度是不一样
一个觉得困在爱情里出不来
一个觉得没有关系
我们让故事留下来就好了
最后我们再分享最后一首歌词
好这首歌词是写给林俊杰的
就是比较近期的作品
而且比较口语化
他叫将故事写成我们
这故事开始一个人
我认真写成了我们这段缘分
没有人转身
你也开始修改剧本
加重我的戏份
初心单纯给了你的吻
只是两个人共同努力
想将我变成我们所有歌名叫做将故事写成我们
我再分享一段
这最美的秘密是我们都在制造巧遇
谁说幸福只是一种远方的消息
思念持续着浓郁梦甘甜下去
誓言继续陪你累积所有回忆
两个人都希望跟对方在一起
所以两个人都是努力的在往同个方向走
所以歌词的意境的结构要很明显
但是男暗恋一个女生
还是说他是他的初恋
他在回忆而已
但是这个很明显是两个人都希望在一起
所以他们双方都会为对方制造相遇的空间
或者是在一起的时间
这是一种感情上
双方都有个默契的一种共同的发展
这一生原本一个人
你坚持厮守成我们却小小声牵着手
在默认感动的眼神说愿意走进我的人生
进了门
开了灯一家人
所以这首歌的基本调性是温暖的
是和谐的
因为两个人在共同追逐同一个目标
歌词有时候就像电影一样
它必须有个调性
可能是公路电影
或者是说谍战片或是奇幻电影
它有个调性
在那调性会决定你歌词的主轴的方向
所以各位同学记得经营歌词文字的时候
除了文字的美跟创意之外
整个故事线的调性也要很统一
要很一致
如果你的调性是和谐的
是温暖的
你不能最后出现一个很突兀的歌词
记得